welcome to ET I'm hahahaha and I'm
mamrie Hart mamrie welcome to Campeche
this is about any table I can make it
better prove it Oh a bottle the shams I
got the bottle is not tiny do you want
just straight up shanstar you want a
mimosa yeah why waste the calories
cheers Cheers nice to see you nice to
see you mmm day 3 of it gone mama needs
you know what I mean right are you
surviving have you heard my voice barely
um no it's been really fun as you can
tell by me sounding like Kathleen Turner
it's a great I'm a reference not for the
kids you know what there are generous I
don't play to my audience my audience
completely I don't see how Hank and John
do it every year it's incredible right
yeah like I get nervous having like 10
people over for dinner and they're
having like 20,000 kids over for
Friday's it's not you've been to camp
before camp Takota yeah god bless always
be plugin uh it was a film that came out
three years ago throwing myself hannah
hart and grace Helbig available on
netflix where itunes but did you were
you a camper as a kid too no i wasn't a
camper but i was a counselor no even
better yeah so every summer of college I
was camp counselor because it's free
room and board you guys honestly it's
like three months ago right I never
thought of that you are in college be a
camp counselor in the summer i'm telling
ya big announcement at VidCon yes so we
have a release date for dirty 30 which
is the party movie that's coming out
with myself grace helping and hannah
hart and it's coming out September honey
heard and the trailer has hit the
internets it has give them give us some
views can happen to use its really it's
exciting it's a party movie it's like
can't hardly wait but 30 years old and a
bunch of girls this is not that camp
Takota was the little by any means but
this is big-time who i like to think so
i'm excited right yeah did you ever
think the first time you made a drink on
youtube that movie star would be in your
future I thought movies bombers in my
future when I came out of the womb baby
come on don't get it twisted mamrie yes
I hope you enjoyed your time at Camp BTW
i had a place i always have a blast
through my face
interviewer what yeah thank you for
saying that on camera yeah of course I'm
gonna talk mean it might be the booze
talking ok perfect I'm out of here
bye-bye